merci la parole et à monsieur rémy de
lattes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
nos campagnes se meurt les élus ruraux
peine à investir dans leur territoire à
cause de la baisse des dotations que
vous leur imposez les populations
entrepreneurs associations luttent rue
contre la désertification des services
publics l'agriculture que vous
abandonnez crie sa détresse
pendant ce temps monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture à temps partiel c'est peu
présents à bruxelles comme le pointe le
rapport d'information de nos collègues
l'écuyer et carresse écrit sur internet
avec d'autres jeunes européens
les lignes ont bougé quelle légèreté
quelle indécence monsieur le ministre
l'état d'urgence agricole appelle des
mesures exceptionnelles pas de
l'autosatisfaction
non monsieur le premier ministre les
lignes n'ont pas bougé dans les fermes
c'est un affront pour nos agriculteurs
qui cette semaine espérer un sursaut un
réveil de votre part et qu'il ne voit ce
conseil européen déboucher que sur la
promesse d'une visite en france du
commissaire européenne à tort conclure
la vanille monsieur le premier ministre
de l'inde et annonce que vous venez de
faire c'est vous qui devriez visiter nos
exploitations pour écouter nos paysans
submergé de charge et de paperasses
écouter nos producteurs anéantie par une
pac l'une est ce une pac calamiteuse aux
zones intermédiaires ou à faible
potentiel comme la côte d'or pour
lesquelles vous n'avez formulé que de
vaines promesses l'état d'urgence
agricole appelle un vrai plan d'urgence
un plan d'ampleur faute de quoi monsieur
le premier ministre nous connaîtrons
dans nos campagnes
un souffle de colère le désespoir et le
drame que vous ne contrôlerez plus
accord le retour de la france sur la
scène européenne des négociations
agricoles
merci la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls seul président
monsieur rémy de là je vous ai connues
plus modéré et plus équilibrée dans vos
expressions très honnêtement je connais
le discours concernant la baisse des
dotations pour ce qui concerne les
communes rurales mais monsieur de lattes
mettez vous d'accord très honnêtement et
120 polémique avec vos propres amis qui
annoncent pour leur propre projet pour
le pays en 2010 est une baisse d une
baisse du budget de l'état de la dépense
publique à un niveau qui de toute façon
toujours et encore davantage si vous me
permettez les collectivités
territoriales à la fois aussi bien s'il
vous plaît en écoulant collectivités
territoriales que sur les moyens pour
les collectivités
c'est deux fois plus peut pas annoncer
100 à 150 milliards de baisses des des
budgets de la dépense publique pour
l'état pour les hôpitaux pour les
collectivités territoriales est
aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'il ya une
question au gouvernement le mardi ou le
mercredi revenir sur la complainte de la
baisse des dotations à chacun de faire
monsieur le député les efforts
nécessaires
du côté de l'état du côté de l'hôpital
du côté des collectivités territoriales
en préservant notre modèle social
il y a là une contradiction et permettez
moi une démagogie qui vous sied guère
et qu'il ne devrait plus aujourd'hui
être entendu ici dans cette assemblée
est la même chose monsieur de la ddt
pour ce qui concerne les agriculteurs la
crise de confiance la crise économique
la crise sociale et la crise morale que
vit une partie de notre instructeur que
vivent les agriculteurs et les éleveurs
dans les filières que nous avons eu
l'occasion de rappeler les rencontres
qui sont multiples qui sont celles
notamment du ministre de l'agriculture
qui peuvent être aussi les miennes au
contact de ces agriculteurs mais le
problème monsieur le député s'est pas de
surfer sur cette crise
c'est pas être dans la démagogie c'est
de dire aussi la vérité aux éleveurs sur
la nécessité de réformes et de
restructurer de restructurer en
profondeur des filières qui aujourd'hui
sont en grande difficulté et c'est ce
qui va être engagée par l'état aux côtés
de la région bretagne avec les
producteurs parce que eux ils savent
plus que tout ce qu'il faut changer
qu'il faut s'adapter
sinon la concurrence venant d'allemagne
ou d'espagne risque d'être mortelle si
elle ne déliera pas pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux et puis au niveau
européen nous agissons nous agissons
j'aurais écouté je pourrais rappelé les
choix qui ont été faits par les
gouvernements précédents ce qui concerne
la pac en ce qui concerne les quotas
laitiers
je peux vous rappeler ce qui a été fait
ici en france avec la lme le niveau
extrêmement faible du plan qui avait été
présentée par monsieur bruno le maire
alors plutôt que d'être dans la
démagogie dans la critique facile
avancer avancer vos propositions
je sais que vous avez été surpris par
les propositions que je viens d'annoncer
un sur jacquot avec dans la démagogie et
vous soutenez ce que nous avons engagé
merci monsieur